et aujourd'hui il y a une inquiétude qui
est qui monte parce que les progrès de
l'intelligence artificielle et notamment
de GPT dans dans sa version numéro 4G
pT4 et sont les progrès sont tellement
rapides que la quasi-totalité des plus
grands spécialistes mondiaux de
l'intelligence artificielle avant-hier
on fait une déclaration qui tient en 22
mots et que je me permets de vous lire
en français parce que la déclaration
était en anglais
réduire les risques de l'extermination
de l'humanité par l'intelligence
artificielle doit être une priorité
globale à côté du risque d'infection de
pandémie et du risque de guerre
nucléaire donc ces experts considèrent
que il y a aujourd'hui une possibilité
si l'on maîtrise mal l'intelligence
artificielle dans dans ces nouvelles
formes comme chaque GPT il y a un risque
d'extinction d'extermination de
l'humanité donc ça devient un sujet
politique ce n'est plus un sujet qui est
limité dans les laboratoires c'est un
sujet qui nous concerne tous ici
qui vous concerne tous qui concerne tous
les auditeurs on peut pas laisser un tel
sujet dans la main des informaticiens
des spécialistes c'est un débat
politique à des bases sociales qui
s'imposent aujourd'hui mais c'est à dire
comment comment ça pourrait arriver dans
Alexandre expliquez-nous pour expliquer
nos téléspectateurs mais ça va arriver
très vite parce que maintenant on est
capable de remplacer
concrètement au niveau des métiers 80%
de nos métiers des métiers qui existent
sur la planète vont être impactés pour
tout ou partie par chat GPT c'est à dire
dans quelques années 80% des gens qui
travaillent vont avoir leur emploi
menacé altéré réduit par chaque GPT donc
c'est extrêmement concret et c'est pour
ça qu'à mon avis il faut endiguer le
phénomène sinon l'homme ne va plus
exister Laurent les métiers de l'homme
vont être remplacés par le robot ce qui
est sûr c'est que jusqu'à présent on
était les sols objets intelligents dans
l'univers
on avait le monopole de l'intelligence
tout d'un coup on voit arriver une
deuxième espèce intelligente qui est
l'intelligence artificielle et qui est
manifestement probablement en train de
nous dépasser en capacité intellectuelle
et donc cette révolution là elle a des
conséquences politiques éducatives il
faut bien évidemment ce que l'école
forme nos gamins au métier de l'air de
chaque GPT et pas à l'heure d'avant
chaque GPT donc le ministre de
l'éducation doit présenter un plan
d'adaptation de l'école pour que nos
gamins soient compétitifs à l'air de
l'intelligence artificielle et puis il
faut aussi que collectivement nous ayons
un débat national et dans chaque pays un
débat politique pour savoir ce que l'on
fait de cette intelligence artificielle
qui n'a pas que de mauvais côté en
médecine en cancérologie on va faire des
progrès absolument inouïe vous avez
probablement vu alors c'est pas une puce
d'Elon musk mais vous avez probablement
vu la semaine dernière grâce à de
l'intelligence artificielle et des
implants dans le cerveau et dans la
moelle on arrive à faire remarcher des
paralysés c'est un truc extra on ne peut
pas considérer que l'intelligence
artificielle n'est porteuse que de
risques elle est aussi porteuse d'une
révolution médicale qui va tous nous
apporter des choses extraordinaires le
progrès scientifique c'est bien quand ça
favorise l'humain quand c'est au service
de l'humain là on a l'impression qu'on
veut desservir l'humain et faire
disparaître complètement les les hommes
et les femmes et les remplacer leur
travail et Gilles tout à l'heure parlait
de 80 % des emplois est-ce qu'on
s'enflamme pas un peu trop par exemple
tu fais remarcher un paraplégique non
mais c'est l'humain mais d'accord mais
justement par comment on fait TPMP avec
chat GPT comment on fait tourner un
restaurant et chat j'ai pété par exemple
alors la réponse à cette question les
les créateurs de chaque GPT sont en
train de créer une gamme de robots les
robots néo donc tu vas avoir des robots
avec l'intelligence d'Aristote dans
quelques années donc on va pouvoir faire
tourner la cuisine d'un restaurant avec
des robots de paix à l'intelligence
artificielle il faut pas penser que la
révolution de l'intelligence
artificielle ne concerne que l'école
blanc que les métiers non manuels les
métiers manuels vont aussi être impactés
parce qu'on voit on va voir apparaître
des des robots dotés de l'intelligence
artificielle donc la gamme de robot Neo
va incorporer chaque GPT version 4 donc
il faut qu'on réfléchisse pour tous les
métiers et le but c'est pas uniquement
pour les métiers non manuels
de nouveaux métiers vont apparaître dans
la création dans l'innovation dans l'art
dans la médecine dans la cancérologie on
va inventer plein de nouveaux métiers
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle le
seul problème c'est qu'il faut pas qu'il
y ait des laissés de côté il faut que il
faut que l'école arrête de glander il
faut que l'école forme nos enfants à
cette révolution mais il y a pas que
l'école il faut que nous aussi on
apprenne à nos enfants à se servir
moi je passe avec mes enfants énormément
de temps pour qu'il se servent bien de
gpt4 de la version 4 de chaque GPT il
s'en sert très bien ils savent comment
poser les questions ils savent comment
travailler mieux plus intelligent grâce
à l'intelligence artificielle chaque
parent chacun d'entre nous doit faire la
même chose il faut que vous accompagnons
nos enfants
[Musique]
en revanche il y a plus de 29000
personnes aujourd'hui qui s'occupent de
diffuser l'eau de nettoyer l'eau de
vérifier la qualité de l'eau donc il y a
plus de porteur d'eau mais les gens qui
gèrent l'eau à Paris ils sont plus
nombreux aujourd'hui que les porteurs
d'eau en 1793 oui mais j'entends les
aspects positifs notamment en médecine
etc mais par ailleurs qui contrôle le
chat j'ai pété c'est à dire la machine
elle-même elle est nourrie par par des
codeurs par des gens qui vont mettre à
disposition de la machine des textes etc
c'est là en fait le vrai souci aussi
parce que c'est là où on peut introduire
des billets et que du coup la page va
donner des informations à nos enfants
que peut-être nous on éprouve par
exemple
bien sûr mais il faut qu'on apprenne nos
enfants à contrôler ce qu'ils entendent
sur le plan numérique mais c'est aussi
vrai quand ils vont sur TikTok ou que
quand ils vont sur Instagram il y a pas
que des choses intelligentes sur
Instagram donc il faut qu'on éduque nos
enfants il faut qu'on les accompagne de
même qu'on apprend aux gamins à rouler
avec un vélo avec des petits trous qui
sont petits mais faut qu'on fasse la
même chose avec l'intelligence
artificielle il faut que nous parents on
fasse avec nos gamins pour
l'intelligence et bien ce qu'on a fait
avec les vélos quand ils étaient tous
gamins et c'est une c'est un engagement
de toute la société il faut absolument
qu'on évite que nos enfants soient
débordés par l'intelligence artificielle
il faut qu'ils en bénéficient et il ne
faut pas qu'il soit larguer le grand
danger aujourd'hui puisque beaucoup de
parents aujourd'hui n'emmènent pas leurs
enfants sur chaque gpt4 c'est que les
enfants soient dépassés quand j'ai pété
5 va arriver j'ai pété 6 j'ai pété 7
j'ai pété 8
[Musique]
donc il vaut mieux il vaut mieux qu'on
habitude aux enfants aux vagues les unes
après les autres plutôt que dans 10 ans
ils se prennent à un tsunami de 100
mètres de haut dans la gueule donc il
est important de mettre nos enfants dans
le bain le plus vite possible pour qu'il
soit pas largué dans le monde du futur
mais ce qui fait un peu peur je trouve
par rapport à justement la nouvelle
l'avancée
technologique de faire marcher le
paraplégique donc si j'ai bien compris
en gros ils ont mis des électrodes dans
le cerveau avec une puce etc à la moelle
épinière et qui donc donne des
informations pour que les gens voilà
l'intelligence artificielle donc en gros
ce que dit par exemple musk c'est à dire
de mettre des puces de pucer les humains
à leur mettre des puces dans le cerveau
c'est à dire en fait il pourrait prendre
le contrôle de nos cerveaux parce que
c'est un peu le but déjà d'Elon musk à
la base il l'a dit déjà c'est il cache
rien il dit voilà moi je me prends le
contrôle de la planète en fait donc il
pourrait finalement si l'implanter des
puces dans les cerveaux humains c'est ça
prendre le contrôle et nous faire faire
des choses puisque on peut faire marcher
quelqu'un qui est pas sincère marcher
donc
après les ovnis on va tous être pucer
c'est un peu alors
quelle est la situation sur neuralink
donc neuraling c'est de se citer qui a
été créée en de il y a 6 ans maintenant
par Elon Musk qui est destiné à mettre
des circuits électroniques dans dans le
cerveau de nos enfants et dans nos
enfants ça par exemple avec
deux étapes il y a une vraie notre
consentement bien sûr bien sûr mais il y
a deux étapes la première étape c'est
pour traiter des maladies d'ailleurs on
le fait déjà dans la mairie de Parkinson
et ça marche bien c'est de traiter des
maladies de permettre aux handicapés de
marcher aujourd'hui les paraplégiques
demain l'état traité de traplégique qui
comme vous savez ne peuvent même plus
actionner leurs bras et dans un deuxième
temps elon Muska un objectif qui est
contenu des progrès très rapide de
chaque GPT de mettre des puces
électroniques dans nos cerveaux et dans
celui de nos enfants pour les rendre
compétitifs face à l'intelligence
artificielle de demain d'ailleurs
deux jours après la sortie de chaque GPT
version 4 Elon Musk a déclaré à la
vitesse à laquelle ça va l'intelligence
artificielle que va-t-il nous rester à
nous humains et il répond la seule
solution que je vois c'est neuralink
c'est à dire d'augmenter nos cerveaux en
mettant des puces électroniques dans le
cerveau
il faut il faut qu'il y ait un débat sur
cette technologie là bien évidemment
qu'il est pas question que nous
acceptions sans débat politique sans
débat médiatique de mettre des puces
électroniques dans le cerveau de nos
gamins en tout cas ce débat sur les
neurotechnologies tire sur les
technologies du cerveau c'est un débat
urgent il faut qu'on l'est moi je ne
vous dis pas que je mettrai des puces
électroniques dans le cerveau de mes
gamins il faut un débat politique sur
ces questions mais Sophie parce que en
fait il explique que comme nous humains
pardon on n'a pas la connaissance de
notre cerveau de la manière dont
fonctionne un cerveau à peu près 10% on
va dire de des compétences cognitives
donc il explique en fait avec cette tus
là on pourrait éventuellement un peu
comme dans Lucie le film de Luc Besson
avoir accès à finalement à toutes les
connaissances et les mécanismes
cognitifs qu'on a pas dans notre cerveau
est-ce que c'est genre de données est-ce
qu'on pourrait avoir accès à notre data
qui sont déjà là
et et vers lesquels c'est pas le faire
potentiellement on peut beaucoup de
choses c'est ce qu'on appelle
le
neuronementation en français c'est
d'augmenter notre fonctionnement
cérébral par des technologies choix des
technologies génétiques et 38% des
Américains depuis la sortie de chaque
GPT souhaite modifier l'ADN les
chromosomes de leur bébé pour qu'ils
soient plus intelligent et rentre dans
une meilleure université
non non mais attends ça a beaucoup
beaucoup étonné les spécialistes de la
de l'éthique aux États-Unis parce que
les Américains étant très religieux
personne n'imaginait qu'il y avait déjà
quasiment 4 américains sur 10 qui
souhaitaient modifier l'ADN de leur bébé
pour le rendre plus intelligent ça a été
une énorme surprise on va avoir l'air
très malin dans quelques années quand on
sera tous brillant intelligents à faire
un air de choses alors que la planète
est en train de crever désolé je veux un
petit parallèle un peu mais bon démago
mais c'est clairement pathétique de
mettre autant de moyens pour faire des
choses comme ça sur le cerveau humain
alors qu'à côté de ça on prédit des
n'oublie pas n'oublie pas l'intelligence
artificielle est en train de commencer à
nous permettre de fabriquer plein de
nouveaux matériaux plein de nouvelles
molécules ça et on va faire des progrès
notamment dans la fusion
donc l'idée qu'on va tous crever comme
le les écologistes ou l'écrivent n'est
pas du tout prouvé les probable que
l'intelligence artificielle va nous
permettre de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique dans les déc
qui viennent le but la fin du monde
n'est pas pour 2050
réussir à faire de façon
[Rires]
à des personnes handicapées et cetera et
aider aux neurosciences
notamment et par ailleurs la dérive
eugéniste elle est clairement identifiée
vous venez de le dire donc cette dérive
là eugéniste elle est extrêmement
flippante c'est à dire qu'on est en
train de dire on va créer le surhomme ou
la surface
c'est pas tellement ça la question qui
angoisse beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va faire des gens
moins intelligents
la réponse c'est d'augmenter pour
diminuer les inégalités intellectuelles
et que tout le monde profite de ce monde
qui arrive
nos désirs nos envies donc une fois
qu'on sera pucé on passera devant dans
une rue à McDo ah tiens comme par hasard
on va commencer à saliver parce que la
puce va nous donner envie d'acheter un
McDo le lendemain d'acheter une voiture
et cetera en fonction des accords si on
sera c'est chaud c'est soldat en fait
alors d'abord il sera qu'un seul
fabricant faire dormir chez Daniel
Moreau il sera pas le seul fabricant de
cette écologie là et puis ces
technologies là vont être encadrées par
le Parlement par la loi dans le futur
vous imaginez bien que nous en tant que
citoyen on va générer un débat politique
un débat social sur ces sujets là et on
va pas laisser le musk satisfaire tous
ces fantasmes de modification de notre
cerveau sanitaire jeudi autorisé aux
États-Unis l'implant pour les maladies
pas pour augmenter les cerveaux encore
mais ça peut quand même soustraire le
libre arbitre à la raison la raison
attendez le débat sur qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de l'intelligence artificielle
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de nos cerveaux
qu'est-ce on fait des technologies qui
modifient notre cerveau en fusionnant
l'intelligence artificielle et nos
cerveaux ce débat il ne fait que
commencer on va pas le boucler on va pas
le boucler ce soir il va durer des
milliers d'années c'est l'enjeu numéro 1
ce qu'on fait notre cerveau ça va être
un grand débat et je pense que vous
allez souvent en parler à cette tribune
j'ai pété pour qu'on interdit pas alors
on interdit pas pour deux raisons c'est
que chaque GPT va permettre de faire des
choses absolument extraordinaires y
compris sur le plan médical et puis d'un
autre côté si on interdisait en Occident
chaque GPT pendant que les Chinois
galopent en intelligence artificielle en
2040 nos enfants auront mandarins
chinois comme première langue et
français comme option langue régional on
ne peut pas abdiquer notre souveraineté
en laissant le pouvoir à la dictature
chinoise donc il y a un problème
géopolitique hélas on n'est pas dans un
monde de bisounours on peut pas donner
les clés du futur on peut pas donner les
clés de l'intelligence artificielle à la
Chine en se retirant
souvenez-vous de ce qui s'est passé en
1450 quand Gutenberg invente
l'imprimerie moderne aussi le sultan
d'Istanbul interdit dans le monde
arabo-musulman et dans le monde ottoman
l'imprimerie
jusqu'en 1727 c'est-à-dire pendant
presque trois siècles l'imprimerie a été
interdit dans tout le monde
arabo-musulman le monde arabo-musulman
était la première puissance mondiale au
Moyen-Âge il est devenu complètement
sous-développé et quand l'imprimerie a
été autorisée en 1727 c'était trop tard
l'Empire ottoman était complètement à la
ramasse était complètement sous
développé nous ne pouvons pas faire la
même chose avec l'intelligence
artificielle nous ne pouvons pas
abandonner les clés du futur à la Chine
nous ne pouvons pas laisser nos enfants
complètement démunis face à la dictature
chinoise qui elle n'arrêtera pas
l'intelligence artificielle
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
qu'est-ce qui va se passer concrètement
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer dans la vie
de tous les jours de ceux qui nous
regardent des personnes qui nous
regardent et voilà dans leur vie de tous
les jours qu'est-ce qui va être remplacé
dans les prochaines années alors une
chose est claire beaucoup d'entre nous
vont se servir des successeurs de chaque
GPT pour travailler d'accord voyez par
exemple
68 % des cas de se servent de GPT CA4 en
le cachant à leur patron bien sûr
évidemment il cache leur patron parce
que si le patron savait qu'il bosse une
demi-heure le matin et qu'il reste du
temps ils glandes parce qu'ils ont fini
leur boulot beaucoup plus vite parce que
chaque GPT peut vous faire en 15
secondes un rapport que vous mettriez
trois jours à faire donc c'est super
pratique pour aller au golf pour glander
et jouer à civilisation derrière sur
l'ordinateur c'est pour ça que les gens
ne s'en vendent pas auprès de leur
patron donc ça c'est la première
modification la deuxième c'est que
chacun d'entre nous va dialoguer avec
son ordinateur avec l'intelligence
artificielle va poser plein de questions
et je vous invite tous à aller sur gpt4
c'est extraordinairement enrichissant et
on peut demander n'importe quoi j'ai
pété 4 c'est bouleversant de puissance
et d'efficacité et j'ai pété quatre et
même très innovants donc ça va changer
nos vies moi je ne suis pas un
pessimiste je crois que la probabilité
que l'intelligence artificielle
extermine l'humanité est assez faible je
ne suis pas comme les gens qui ont signé
la pétition paniqués avec l'impression
que nous allons être exterminé par
l'intelligence artificielle je suis
persuadé que nous nous humains nous
allons nous enrichir au contact de
l'intelligence artificielle je suis
convaincu que nous allons trouver les
moyens d'encadrer l'intelligence
artificielle et je pense que nous
rentrons dans une deuxième Renaissance
dans une période extraordinaire sur le
plan technologique sur le plan médical
sur le plan scientifique je suis très
optimiste et je vous invite plutôt à
être optimiste que paniqué par rapport à
ces sujets